in business uh i've lost a lot in the
last you know 21 years of being in the
financial industry it's a very
very competitive i've lost a lot of
clients to other companies i've lost
agents i've lost employees i've lost
contracts
and
you know it was very easy to say well
you know in the industry today
uh you know it's because i'm armenian
it's because i'm from iran one time i
lost the contract to a big company
because they were concerned i was
armenian and you know uh
what do you call it there was a couple
armenian insurance frauds going on in
glendale and they said you're part of
that community i said no here's where
i'm at this is my business is this model
so well we had a bad experience because
we had a two million dollar charge back
i said no i said i want you to judge me
for who i am i don't want you to judge
me for what my ethnicity is let's see
this and let's see what we can do and i
want to compete and i kept our contract
we're best best friends still today the
same people that were going to drop my
contract 11 years ago they had me at
their retirement ceremony speaking
amongst five people and i was second to
the closing speaker and the closing
speaker was his best friend of 26 years
so for me
the challenge i have is
to to say i have to you know compromise
my values to win
i'd much rather say my messaging has to
improve my ability to go out there and
shake more hands has to improve my
ability to market better has to improve
i have to out market you out message you
out work you even if you're cheating and
there's a lot of people that cheat in
the marketplace in business in media and
politics definitely more in politics
than other areas yeah you got to get
more creative with the messaging to win
because
that that that angle and again this is
my opinion
that gets the voter to say
well why vote anyways because we don't
stand a chance against the globalist why
do it anyway that that's actually the
wrong messaging because it doesn't get
the crowd to come out for example like
right now what happened with trump
okay
right now what happened with trump for
example
this is the
uh uh brilliant marketing of him and
where he's at love him hate him do
whatever you want to do with the guy do
you know how they're going to use this
here what that happened with fbi here's
how marketer
they're going to get their base
to show up like never before okay that's
how they're going to use it because in
the world of politics
it's it's definitely the dirtiest
amongst all okay because you can
manipulate a lot and get away with it
you can't really do that a lot in
business and get away with it because
there's laws in politics there's not
really laws you just got to kiss the
right person's ass and you know
you can lie get away with a lot of
different things in business you're
eventually going to get caught when you
lie too often it's just it's just what
ends up happening if you do that bad
business yeah it's bad business and
insurance you can send a bunch of
premium but if doesn't stay on the books
you're eventually going to be
you know having that reputation so
for me i i want to agree with you but i
want to also challenge you to say hey
man if i got to go back i got to change
my strategy marketing we got to have
better team we got to shake more hands i
got to build a bigger pipeline today i
got to get better endorsements maybe
bannon is good strategically maybe it's
not a good public strategic thing for me
to have out there maybe i got to have
him as somebody i talk to on the phone
on a daily basis but publicly the people
that so that's the only thing i would
say with some of those things because if
you're really going to go do the
politics thing
you have to know like i remember one
time i had a guy named casey bell he was
in the military total playboy great with
the ladies and one day i'm 17 18 i'm
like i just can't stand the games these
girls are playing he says what are you
talking about
they're playing so many games he says
you got to play the games back
it's part of it
it's a game no but but by the way not no
not from the standpoint you don't play
games
not from the standpoint of not from the
standpoint of manipulation
what he's talking about is they're
playing hard to get that's part of it
you got to figure out a way to still
move them you got to figure out a way to
still persuade them that's the part and
by the way that's politics
yes
no
no i strongly disagree with this okay
tell me why
there are sacred honor are the ideas and
the values that you live by but are
willing to die for
and to have a radical loss of sacred
honor in this country
and people around the world
and
as soon as you you know when you say out
message i mean
and i and i told our our delegates this
in in the
cd uh five
um convention where they endorse a
candidate
um
if you guys want to become democrats to
win in a deep blue
place you don't really win
i mean you don't win if you become a
democrat to get a democrat vote you have
to convert a democrat to conservative
ideas or liberals to conservative ideas
if you become a liberal to win you're
just a mouthpiece
you're just saying that though but no
but this
but this is what i'm saying there are
fundamental ideas yeah
that didn't fall on or didn't fall to a
lack of messaging there are real
contention about ideas and because we
live in a democracy we play this retail
game with the people and say well how
can i get the widest net but there are
some things that we should have never
compromised on that somebody has to
stand up and say just just know
absolutely not and in a place like
minnesota that's
very moderate conservatives even on the
republican side
abortion was that issue
i could have went door to door and
affirmed abortion baby killing
and i would have easily gotten another
500 what i'm saying though but but when
you start down the path
of modifying a message
based on what people would like to hear
as soon as it ventures away from being
truth things that you know to be true or
or things that you believe in yeah
you're already down
you become
you become a product of whatever the the
most powerful
leveraging dog is out there in the yard
and that's how this that's how we lost
this country so i'll give you an idea
okay do you know what life insurance
used to be called
death insurance death insurance mm-hmm
so would you rather buy life insurance
or death insurance
wouldn't matter to me but the average
person is gonna buy insurance so maybe
that's insurance as a creepy moment but
if you go you go to a family and say hi
i'd like to buy you some death
insurance today versus life insurance
right okay
so you know uh uh
anti-abortion or pro-life what's better
exactly it's the same thing it used to
be it wasn't being called pro-life
same thing so
abortion or pro-life
you have to know that's messaging it's
the smart thing so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]